هجوم ان جديد يستهدف القوات الامريكيه في
سوريا القياده المركزيه للجيش الامريكي
اعلنت ان صواريخ سادفت خلال الليله
الماضيه قوه التحالف الدولي الذي تقوده
واشنطن في هذه ابرز قواعدها في شمال شرق
سوريا اذن من دون ان تسفر عن سقوط ضحايا
هذه المنطقه تعتبر استراتيجيه باعتبر انها
محاديه لحقل العمر النفطي ويقع شرقيه
محافظه دير الزور وهو كان اغزر الحقول
السوريه قبل عام 2011 قبل ان يتحول منذ
2018 الى قاعده عسكريه
وفرضت حوله منطقه حضر عسكري يمنع الاقتراب
معنا حول الموضوع همم مدير المدرسه حقوق
الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن من القاهره
تحديدا اهلا بك استاذ رامي بدايه هل من
تفاصيل جديده حول طبيعه الاضرار التي ربما
قد تكون لحقت بهذه القاعده بسبب هذه
الصواريخ حول الجهه التي اطلقت منها
نعم مساء الخير طبعا القاعده هي ذاتها حق
العمر هو اكبر قاعده عسكريه امريكيه
والصواريخ مصدرها ضفاف الفرات الغربيه
ميليشيات ايران يرجح بانها من الجنسيه
العراقيه هي التي استهدفت القاعده باربعه
الصواريخ سقطت في منطقه حصول عماره اما
على الاضرار الماديه
والبشريه لا نستطيع يعني تاكيدها كون ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تفرض الطوقاني
على تلك المنطقه وتعتبر المنطقه امنيه
وعسكريه بعد الاستهداف كان هناك اعاده
تموضع وانتشار عند ضفاف الفرات الغربيه
ايران التي يتواجد فيها حزب الله
اللبنانيه الحرس الثوري
الايرانيات سوريه افغانيه وايضا التزامل
مع تحليق للطائرات المروحيه الامريكيه على
طول نهر الفرات من البوكمال وصولا الى
مدينه دير الزور وتحقيق الطائرات
الاستطلاع الامريكيه
طيب سيدرا يعني السؤال المطروحه حول هل من
توقيت ربما هل من شيء يبرر هذا الهجوم
يقال انه جاء بعد ايام فقط من قصف اللي
قافله مواد محروقات كانت متوجهه نحو لبنان
هل هناك علاقه بين هذا الهجوم وصواريخ هذا
هذه الليله ام هناك ربما تفسير اخر برايك
حتى اللحظه التي لم يعلن من نفذ الهجوم
على قافله الصهاريه النفط التي كان يوجد
فيها اسلحه وصاني الذي استلفت كان فيها
اسلحه ايضا ولكن في النهايه
المعلا كانت قافل الصواريخ التاسع من
الشهر الجاري وادت بطل 14 عنصرا من
السائقين البولين ايران والتي والذين يرجع
بانهم عناصر من الحرس الثوري الايراني ومن
اللبنانيين لكن ايضا الذين اقول بان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حينها
من استهدفه هذا الرجل بشكل قطعي الثعلب
الولايات المتحده اكثر من المرصد من ابتدى
بهذا اللون
في المرصد ومتابعتكم لتطورات على الارض
يعني اي دور بات لهذه القوات الامريكيه من
همم يعني الى جانب دعم قوه قصد قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه اي دور تقوم به هذه القوات
التي بقيت هناك في سوريا
داخل الاراضي السوريه تلك المنطقه هي
المنطقه نفسيه ونعلم بان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تفرض عقابات عقوبات اقتصاديه
قاسيه على مناطق سيطره النظام ولا تريد من
هذا النفط ان يكون تحت سيطره النظام لذلك
باقيه في تلك المنطقه الى ان مثل ما يقال
تنتهي من حركه تنظيم داعش
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد رامي عبد الرحمن مدير
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان كنت معنا من
العاصمه المصريه القاهره